In 1986, Castlevania took players inside Dracula's
sprawling, horrifying mansion, and gamers
never looked back.
Now, over three decades later, Castlevania
isn't just a major video game series, it's
also an animated series, a series of comic
books, and the origin of an entire video game
genre.
And just like Vlad's castle, Castlevania is
full of secrets.
There's much more to the game than whips and
vampires.
Mysterious origins
Over 30 official Castlevania games have been
published, and a few are even considered to
be some of the greatest games of all time,
so there's no doubt that Castlevania is an
important franchise.
And yet, historians have no clue who actually
created the thing.
Koji Igarashi, Castlevania's longtime producer
and the name most commonly associated with
the franchise, didn't start working on the
series until 1997's Symphony of the Night.
Castlevania doesn't have a "real" credit sequence,
ending with a tribute to people like "Christopher
Bee" and "Boris Karloffice."
Why don't we know who made this game?
In the '80s and early '90s, Japanese game
developers used pseudonyms at the behest of
their bosses in order to make it harder for
rival companies to poach talented staff members.
Some historians have tried to track down Castlevania's
creator, but haven't gotten much further than
the name "Hitoshi Akamatsu", but other than
a handful of credits on other Konami games,
nobody seems to know much about him.
From the looks of things, Mr. Akamatsu exited
the game industry in the '90s and disappeared
— if he ever existed at all.
Beyond Nintendo
The first three numbered Castlevania games
launched on the Nintendo Entertainment System,
leading to the impression that the series
started as an NES-exclusive franchise… except
it didn't.
Only a month after the first game debuted,
the second entry in the series, Vampire Killer,
arrived on Microsoft's MSX computer as a Japan
exclusive, and Nintendo also ran Castlevania
in some of their Versus System arcade cabinets.
There's also Haunted Castle, Castlevania's
first original arcade outing, which is regarded
as a pretty terrible, incredibly difficult
game with awful controls.
Even worse, Simon Belmont only has one life,
and you can only continue three times, no
matter how many quarters you pump into the
machine.
It wasn't long before the Belmonts and friends
broke out onto every system out there, — but
even early on, Nintendo wasn't the franchise's
exclusive distributor.
Bram Stoker's Dracula
It's pretty obvious that Castlevania owes
quite a bit to Bram Stoker's vampire magnum
opus, but just how much?
Konami made Stoker's book part of the official
timeline in Castlevania: Bloodlines.
According to Konami, the book's Quincey Morris,
who helps Jonathan Harker kill Dracula before
succumbing to his vampire-induced wounds,
is actually a member of the Belmont line.
In the game series, Quincy dispatched Dracula
and went on to father Bloodlines' hero John
Morris.
Jonathan, from Castlevania: Portrait of Ruin,
is Quincy's grandson.
It's not a perfect fit, however.
According to Bloodlines, John saw Quincy murder
Dracula when he was a kid, and without Harker's
help.
As a storytelling device, linking Stoker and
Castlevania raises more questions than it
answers.
As a tribute to Castlevania's primary inspiration,
however?
It works just fine.
Alucard's origins
One of the most popular characters in Castlevania
is Alucard, Dracula's half-vampire son, and
the hero of Castlevania: Symphony of the Night,
a noble and fierce warrior who's put his dad
back in the ground and saved humanity multiple
times.
While everything about his backstory reeks
of classic video games, Alucard, like his
old man, is actually lifted from older source
material.
While not as well known as 1931's Dracula,
the film's second sequel, 1943's Son of Dracula,
is actually responsible for Alucard.
In the film, horror star Lon Chaney Jr. plays
the mysterious Count Alucard, who seduces
a young heiress with promises of immortality.
Of course, 'Alucard' is just 'Dracula' spelled
backwards… so even though 1943 wasn't great
at being subtle, the name stuck.
Animated adventures
Netflix's Castlevania is the first video-game-to-film
adaptation to earn a "fresh" score on Rotten
Tomatoes, with a rating of 90 percent.
But it's not even the first Castlevania-themed
cartoon.
In 1989, DIC Entertainment produced a Saturday
morning cartoon called Captain N: The Game
Master, and characters from Castlevania played
a major role.
Captain N tells the story of a teenager named
Kevin Keene who gets sucked into his Nintendo
and faces off against villains from various
8-bit video games, including deranged versions
of Punch-Out's King Hippo and Metroid's Mother
Brain.
Along the way, Kevin gets help from Mega Man,
Kid Icarus, a sentient Game Boy, and Castlevania's
first leading man, Simon Belmont.
"I'm Simon Belmont, vampire hunter, at your service."
In Captain N, Simon is a vain adventurer who
cares more about his dashing good looks than
fighting evil... which is a pretty unfaithful
adaptation, as far as cartoons go.
Dracula shows up as a recurring villain, and
Alucard shows up in the third season episode
"Return to Castlevania," as a wisecracking
teenager with sunglasses, a bat-shaped skateboard,
and an unhealthy obsession with rock and roll.
"Yo pops! Check out my new bat flip!"
It was pretty much the most cringeworthy early-'90s
thing ever, and thankfully, that version of
Alucard quickly disappeared and never returned.
"Alright!
Vampires rule!"
Timelines
You don't make almost 20 games in ten years
without making a few mistakes, but there's
one decision in particular that Koji Igarashi
wishes that he could take back.
While developing Symphony of the Night, Igarashi
developed a series timeline for the developers
to use as an internal reference.
Once it leaked to a gaming magazine, the Castlevania
team decided to make it official.
According to the timeline, Dracula returns
every 100 years, but unfortunately, the official
timeline is so thorough that Igarashi said
that it hurt his creative process down the
line, explaining,
"...since Dracula only appears every 100 years,
we made the whole timeline and ran out of
places to put in another game."
Of course, when continuity gets too crowded,
you can just throw it all out and start over.
That's what Konami did in 2010 when it handed
a new developer the reins to Castlevania:
Lords of Shadow, which takes place in an entirely
different universe… but that game almost
didn't happen at all.
Metal Gear Shadow
In the late 2000s, Konami enlisted MercurySteam
to create a brand new, 3D reboot of the Castlevania
franchise.
The developers put together a prototype and
showed it to Konami's executives, but they
grew nervous about all the changes that were
being made to their classic franchise, so
they stripped away the Castlevania branding
and allowed development to continue.
Lords of Shadow made its public debut at Gamescom
2009.
Later that year, MercurySteam showed the latest
version of Lords of Shadow to Konami higher-ups,
which included Metal Gear Solid overlord Hideo
Kojima.
Kojima loved it and asked the room, "Why isn't
this Castlevania?"
Eventually, Kojima joined Lords of Shadow
as a producer, and though he'd later leave
Konami, Kojima is uniquely responsible for
the continuation of Castlevania as we know
it.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!